[Music]
we are welcoming back today a longtime
friend of the show
benjamin dixon host of the benjamin
dixon show
resident of the all-important state of
georgia we are going to talk about what
already happened in georgia what may
happen on january 5th ben it's so good
to see you
david it's always good to see you good
to be back here sharing with your
channel congratulations on the million
subscribers oh thank you a million one
million two now right well listen you're
going to get there faster than i did
it'll you're not there yet but uh you're
you're compressing my growth into
less time i'm sure i certainly hope so
because it already feels like it's been
forever it's been
it's been like six years so uh but we're
just still doing the work and excited
about what's happening in georgia
yeah so i mean let's just dive right
into it first of all
you know there were questions will texas
go red i never
i'm sorry will texas go blue i never
thought it would what's going to happen
in florida
i thought it was kind of a question mark
i i did not think
georgia was the most likely to go to joe
biden but it did
you followed it in a way that that i
didn't from outside of the state were
you surprised
right no i wasn't i was pleased i was
thoroughly pleased but i knew
the kind of work that was happening on
the ground i knew the type of
registrations that were happening
um the new georgia project which is
affiliated with stacey abrams
and a couple of other colleagues of mine
new georgia project registered
half a million people of color alone in
this cycle
and so with those kind of numbers
and the type of targeted push that i saw
on the ground i suspected that georgia
would be blue
i just didn't want to jinx it so i kept
my fingers crossed
so we've got these two senate races
and john ossoff david perdue there's no
more debates there
um i i almost had to call atlanta police
and report a murder after that first
debate with assaf and perdue i mean
that's one of the most brutal debates
i've ever seen and i understand why
david perdue's not debating we had
the leftler warnock debate on sunday
and she seemed to have a software
malfunction where she was repeating the
same five things over and over
including the word socialist
and a radical leftist radical liberal
raphael warnock
my instinct and my audience was this is
so transparent
but we don't necessarily understand the
totality of the electorate
in georgia is that type of repetition
actually something that could win you a
senate race in georgia
no no but what can win you incineration
georgia is simply
being complicit and part and parcel with
the power structure that kelly lefler
represents and what she's trying to
protect so
they don't care how incompetent she is
she's theirs she's that that's that's
their con that's their senator that's
the person
who they're going to vote for i mean
they voted for donald trump right i know
joe biden won but there's still a lot of
people in georgia who support
trumpism so um do they support her
malfunction because she did have a
software malfunction to be sure
no they probably think she's she's bland
as a borg
but they're still going to vote for her
and in terms of voting at
all and this is something that i am just
fascinated by
on the one hand early it was it's rigged
rigged rig
trump really won etc which would imply
january 5th could maybe is also rigged
and then you started seeing inklings of
this
let's just boycott republicans boycott
if they're not going to count our votes
anyway let's just boycott
which of course is crazy because that
will just hand the wins to to the two
democratic candidates
but lately in trump's rally during the
debate you saw leffler say it
they're now focusing on the importance
of getting out every vote do you think
that this boycott movement will have any
impact
well i i will say that the republicans
here in the state of georgia
are pretty much like the republicans
across the country
they they're doing their best to hold it
together
while they figure out what the hell to
do with donald trump and
that's happening in georgia so people
don't really know republicans don't
really know whether they are free to
distance themselves from donald trump
nobody is going to attack him
but they are afraid to distance
themselves and so there's kind of a
kerfuffle right there's there's
confusion there's chaos there's dissent
in uh georgia republicans we see some of
them just uh
disagreeing with each other publicly
they're going in different directions in
terms of strategy
um i i think they are collapsing under
the weight of donald trump's ego
and i think that's going to have a huge
effect in january and so but but as far
as just like this idea of them
staying home as some kind of solidarity
with the claims
that it was rigged only a few percent
need to do that for it to potentially
make a difference given how close it's
expected to be
right because the uh special elections
the the uh special elections on january
5th
the turnout is going to be by definition
lower right it's a special election
and so the margins are going to be that
much more important so if they actually
do
manage to get like one percent even just
one percent of georgia's turnout
uh republican turnout to stay home um
then that could be the margin of
difference here
i've been having not really an argument
but kind of a disagreement about
strategy with some in my audience where
last week i said listen
for 10 years on this program i've been
saying increase
civic engagement voting is is a it's
step one it's only step one but it is
step one
increase turnout overall the left does
better with more turnout
and so i would not feel okay saying
hey republicans you know you really
should stay home you really should
boycott this thing because i feel like
at a higher level it's not what i'm
about
now some people in my audience wrote to
me and they said listen david if
democrats take the senate and kamala
harris becomes the tie-breaking vote
things will get done that would not
otherwise get done
the country will be better off isn't
there some greater good in just this
one time encouraging republicans not to
vote even if you have to lie to them
about the rig stuff
i can't get behind that like i i'm
having a lot of trouble with that
what's your thought on this this idea no
no it's a great question because i'm
actually
i'm senior advisor for really american
and they are running some really
provocative ads in georgia billboards
particularly they have billboards all
over the state
that are basically basically encouraging
republicans to continue fighting each
other
right and and in a way if you're not
careful it could have
a suppressive effect against republicans
because
if republicans feel like they have a lot
of infighting they're more likely to
stay home
i'm okay with that um i and i 100
understand where you come from david and
and i find myself uh struggling with
that on a regular basis well let me
clarify ben just to be make sure i know
what you're saying you're saying you're
okay
i'm okay with them staying home if they
want to convince each other to stay home
that's great i'm not going to say you
know you really should vote where i
sort of draw the line is participating
in the encouragement
to stay home because it's rigged well
we're participating in what
um uh my colleague at really american
calls a truth-telling campaign
okay watch the spin yeah it was a great
spin so
he said all we're doing is telling the
truth about what's going on in the
georgia republican party
i think the people of georgia have the
right to understand the divisions that
are happening in the republican party so
we're calling what we're doing a
truth-telling campaign and and you know
i know you know we could read between
the lines yeah we want to win georgia
and
then um you guys could you know people
who disagree with me not you
particularly uh but y'all could come
after us afterwards we're gonna we're
gonna win this race
and uh and then and then we'll feel bad
about what we did afterwards
so you're you're confident about the the
two uh races
i'm i'm i'm pretty uh i'm pretty bullish
on it i i feel
um i feel that if everything falls in
place
we could pull out a miracle it will be a
miracle right it's not going to be easy
but i think all the elements are in
place and i think if everyone plays
their cards right we could get two seats
and i know that's a stretch
but i'm willing to to to go out on the
limb there
let's talk a little bit about the
incoming
biden administration uh i said
months ago i will call it the way i see
it if i see joe biden pick people that i
think are problematic i will tell you
it won't mean that i think i should have
voted for trump instead it will just
mean i voted for the right person but
they made some selections i didn't like
so far the two that i am concerned about
primarily are nira tandon um absolutely
and lloyd austin and you know uh back in
2017 i said when jim mattis was selected
uh guys we we have a rule about being
out of the military seven years
so what's the point of the rule if you
can just get a congressional waiver and
get around that there's a reason that
that rule is in place
the exact same waiver is going to be
necessary for lloyd austin
and i would be a hypocrite if i didn't
call it out he was involved in some of
the mishandling
of of the iraq war in 2011 and in 2014.
this this is not a pick i love and to me
it strikes me
as identity diversification
without solving the structural problems
right right i mean so there's always
going to be david there's there's always
going to be an element
in the corporate democratic wing that is
more than happy to give us
uh identity um you know
because it is it is a it is it instantly
celebrated
that this is a black guy who's gonna
lead the pentagon right with lloyd
austin yep um
but you know we just take a break and
breathe and look and say oh well this is
that guy
and so i think it's um you know that's
our job
our job is going to be to maneuver
through the bs of them using identity
uh as a shield like i think identity
politics matters i want to make sure i
say that i think identity politics
matters
because black people and and all kind of
identities suffer
identity specific problems in this
country there are problems that black
people go through simply because they
are black
lgbtqia obviously however when the
corporate democrats use it as a shield
against criticism
we have to be able to maneuver through
that and still bring a solid critique
against their uh their corporate
their corporatism and imperialism right
the phrase i've used is
i value identity because of the insight
it gives us
but where i stop is whether it's used as
either a shield
or a cudgel to or a mallet to beat
people sort of over the head
and that's where the rational thinking
seems to go out right
well i mean and i agree with you i agree
with you all the way to the point where
i think that there are some situations
in this country that require a mallet to
the head
i think that there are some very
stubborn situations
in this country that are so intrinsic
and malignant to be quite honest
like racism is malignant in this country
and and if we need to go
straight head-to-head with it then fine
but we have to be able to understand
when it's time
to recognize how identity politics just
like any
i mean any other politics are used
against you
for powerful people to continue getting
their way into getting their agenda and
we just have to know when that's
happening with identity
yeah and interestingly i mean it's good
you mentioned that because oftentimes
class politicking is also used in ways
that but it's just not identified as
pernicious
and with the phrase oh identity politics
is being
used you rarely hear that said about
class politics but it's used very
frequently yeah
yeah and see i class politics is an
identity of politics that i get down
with i'm like
i'm down with like four flat tires with
class politics as well as race racial
politics
uh but i agree with you right it is if
you're not careful there's an element of
a class critique
that itself can become a cultural it
could become a bludgeoning tool it could
become
a weaponized um way to ignore
logic and reason right so we just have
to be careful that anything that we
really believe in can be weaponized
against
us uh if we're if we if we give it a
free pass and not
or and we're not willing to critique it
truthfully and in good faith
so who do you like that joe biden has
selected so far
um
nobody nobody no no i'm sir i'm really
trying to think of any uh
cedric i forget cedric's last name
congressman um who had that
brilliant exchange with matt gates about
his son i can't think of cedric's love
for last name but he
he's okay i don't i'm not i'm honestly
i'm not excited about any of his picks
i am what i have decided to do with joe
biden is to
let him make his play let him make his
play i can't control who he picks no
matter how much commentary we give we
can't control who he picks but we can
decide
what type of um opponent we have in the
white house
is the opponent that we have to oppose
with all of our energy or is the
opponent that we need to
keep an eye on because he made some bad
picks and we need to keep an eye on what
they're going to do
i think he's going to fall in that
latter category yeah i mean i i've said
that i
i dug back into some of uh janet
yellen's economic writing from the 90s
which where she was like an academic uh
economist she's she's pretty brilliant
and i mean it's like listen she's gonna
she's gonna run
the the treasury and um she believes in
monetary policy you know like that that
we would expect that joe biden is going
going to pick somebody like that
yes but uh things like her fair wage
hypothesis from 1990 which i would
definitely check out if you've not read
it yeah
very very interesting stuff she is quite
brilliant and
at least i think she will not stand in
the way if joe biden can otherwise get
consensus and political
capital to get things done i don't think
she'll stand in the way of anything he's
he campaigned on whether he'll do it is
a different question yeah and i think
that's
that is the million-dollar question
right so what does
joe biden really want to do right the
rest of this is on the periphery
right he's going to do a lot of things
because there's a lot of people in a lot
of departments who have their own
agendas
and he's going to filter through them
and they'll get whatever their agenda is
done
right which is why i'm really leery
about the possibility of rahm emanuel
because
i just kind of have a feeling i know
what this guy wants and it's never been
anything good for black people or poor
people
that said uh with everyone else joe
biden is picking
i want to see what joe biden actually
wants because what he actually wants is
what he's going to put his energy behind
david i'm afraid that what he really
wants is bipartisanship with the
republicans i think his end-all goal
might be bipartisanship
and then then that is somebody i have to
take a pretty good stand against but
yeah that's completely nice
i mean that's just totally elected him
though i'm still glad we elected him of
course yeah
no but the idea that you're going to get
things done with the help of this
republican party
it it seems like the height of naivete
yes
yes and and i don't know if joe biden i
think possibly with joe biden it could
be sincere naivete
i think what people around him who
always triangulate with republicans i
think
it is intentional because they probably
identify with republicans more than they
they do progressives but with joe biden
i don't know the jury is still out i
think he actually believes that
bipartisanship
is the greater good yeah we will uh i
think we'll know relatively quickly is
the upside i think by march 1st we'll
have a pretty good sense of whether he
he really believes that
ben dixon the benjamin dixon show so
you've got the audio podcast
you've got the facebook and the youtube
channel and you seem to have
like a dozen ancillary shows that i
regularly am catching
streams of so like what what's the the
hub where people can
what's the best place i mean you know
what they honestly can go to the youtube
channel right here on youtube subscribe
on youtube um
uh give us a please sir can we have some
more of your subscribers
david can we have some more of your
subscribers you know the beautiful thing
about youtube subscribers is
like when me and when sam cedar and i
were having this fake war to a million
yeah it's not zero sum it's not you have
one subscript subscription and you
either give it
to sam or to banner to david you can
generate
subscriptions infinitely just by
subscribing to more than one channel so
i always say
spread the wealth around hey man i
appreciate that see that's where i rock
with david and david for everyone who
doesn't know
david has been rocking with my show
since i started my show like maybe
six months after i started my show david
contacted me so man i appreciate
everything that you've done to help me
on this journey
my my pleasure and um let's let's do it
again very soon
sounds good take care man